only on CBS this morning we have more of
banker Trump's first interviews
assistant to the president she had to
put her own business career on hold in
order to work for her dad so did her
husband Jared Kushner a White House
senior advisor so we asked her about the
challenge of separating from their
corporate interests and how their new
public role is working out people are
fascinated very fascinated by you and
Jared particularly now fascinated by the
role that Jared is playing he seems to
be doing a lot let's talk about dealing
with Mexico China running an office of
innovation brokering peace in the Middle
East he's now in Iraq how is he able to
do all of that and what are his
qualifications that's the other thing
people are saying how can a person who
has no military and political experience
be involved on such a high level in this
administration you know a lot of people
would say the same about how could
somebody successfully win the presidency
who had never been engaged in politics
and my father did that and Jared wood is
instrumental in helping his campaign
succeed so you know Jared is incredibly
smart very talented has enormous
capacity he is humble in the recognition
of what he doesn't know and is
tremendously secure in his our ability
to to seek informed viewpoints he has an
amazing team that my father has built at
the White House and that he's built
that's helping work on each of these
initiatives so you know the myth that
he's operating in a silo is is just that
you're the phrase complicit that Jared
and Ivanka are complicit in what is
happening to the White House can you
just weigh in on how you feel about that
there have been articles there been
parodies what do you think about that
that accusation
if being complicit is wanting to be a
force for good and to make a positive
impact
then I'm complicit I don't know that the
critics who may say that of me if they
found themselves in this very unique and
unprecedented situation that I am now in
would do any differently than I'm doing
so I hope to make a positive impact
know what it means to be complicit but
but you know I hope time will prove that
I have done a good job and much more
importantly that my father's
administration is the success that I
know it will be when we talk about the
Ivanka Trump brand you are no longer
running the day-to-day no I'm no what
have you done with your business
I have no involvement with any of it I
felt like proximity to my father into
the White House and with my husband
taking such an influential role in the
administration I didn't want to also be
running a business so I put it into
trust
I have independent trustees I have no
involvement in its management and its
oversight and its strategic decision
making but the trustees are family
members right your brother-in-law and
your sister-in-law they are so if
they're completely independent and I'm
transparent about that can you see from
the public point of view yes you put it
in trust but it's family members are
thinking well is he/she really not
involved do you really not get on the
phone and say what's going on do you
have no invite Taylor I take a legal
document very seriously and I wouldn't
go through the pains of setting this up
if I intended to violate it did you
think about selling the business because
the name of the business is Ivanka Trump
had I have sold the business an
independent third party would be able to
go around the globe today licensing and
leveraging the name of the 45th
president in the United States of
America
completely unfettered because I think
the big concern people that I keep
hearing out there is that the family is
benefiting financially in their own
personal business while your father is
in the White House in all sorts of ways
I would argue that if I had not come to
Washington DC and if I was in New York
growing my business I would be doing far
better than by placing the restrictions
I have placed on my team and ensuring
that any growth is done with extreme
caution
so just practically speaking if my
interest was making money or growing my
business I would do far better to
completely disengage and do exactly that
some people say well I hadn't thought
about it that way you know it was
interesting to see the reaction in the
room when she was me and it's clear that
she's thought about these questions yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't think that she
knew what we were coming to ask she had
some idea we didn't really discuss there
was nothing that was off-limits in the
interview and you're asking what
everybody wants to know yeah yeah all
right
and she wanted that's I think Charlie
the reason why she wanted to do the
interview there's so many misconceptions
about her how she operates what she does
and and how she lives away she lives and
she said you know I just really want
people to see I'm not trying to break
the rules change the rules I'm following
the rules and I want people to know
that's what I'm doing and being very
transparent about it there's something
to be said for delivering advice in
private yep you're absolutely right in
our next hour the president's daughter
speaks out about family life in
Washington which includes new adventures
like monster truck shows what that's
ahead on CBS this morning